[Musique]
je suis vraiment heureux de souhaiter à
chacune à chacun d'entre vous la
bienvenue au Sénat cette troisième
rencontre organisée dans le cadre du
congrès des maires de France est un
moment privilégié qui nous donne
l'occasion de manifester l'attachement
du Sénat aux élus municipaux et sa
volonté de toujours mieux les associer à
nos travaux
nous avons souhaité cette année mes
collègues que je salue et moi
nous mettre à l'écoute des élus des
communes directement et sans filtre
comme la rappeler le président Larcher
afin d'entendre vos préoccupations et
les faire évidemment remonter vous
représentez en effet le premier maillon
de la République et de l'action au
service des citoyens la présente édition
donne donc la priorité au dialogue au
regard croisés et aux témoignages de
terrain
dans les outre-mer les problématiques se
ressemblent finalement et le fait
d'échanger nous permet de nous permettre
peut-être de trouver des solutions
tous les évolutions tout ce qu'on
demande au niveau du Sénat et nous
écoute ils sont à notre écoute la
délégation que président de sénateur et
qui nous est accompagne bien dans nos
démarches dans nos besoins il y a
peut-être 20 ans on n'avait pas ses
jambes ces gens de changer c'était
plutôt on peut tabou on ne pouvait pas
discuter avec le sénateur on pouvait pas
assister à des débats ce sont des gens
qui ont mis en oeuvre un changement pour
la collaboration parce que c'est le
Sénat c'est les territoires et les
territoires effectivement tous les
territoires régulièrement des docteurs
[Musique]